I'm Bill Gates chairman of Microsoft
Microsoft makes profits of about 1.5
billion dollars per month
[Music]
have you noticed that Microsoft has
fallen out of the spotlight compared to
their Tech peers Microsoft is rarely on
the news and not many people have a
strong opinion about the company in fact
I'd argue that Microsoft is the most
prominent tech company that people don't
have a strong opinion about with apple
there's the whole controversy about
their premium pricing and their
anti-user policies with Facebook and
Google you've got the entire privacy
argument with Amazon you've got the bald
slave driver controversy and with
Netflix well a lot of people are happy
that they're getting crushed this isn't
to say that we aren't dependent on
Microsoft though the vast majority of
the world still uses windows and even if
you're a Mac User you probably still use
Microsoft Office yet despite their
popularity we rarely talk about
Microsoft as a company I mean they're
literally not even part of paying it and
their public interest is virtually
non-existent in comparison to Fang
despite this Microsoft's business as a
whole is doing better than ever in fact
their gross margins are nearly 70
percent and their net margins are nearly
40 percent if Apple had these margins
people would be shredding them to Pieces
but because it's Microsoft no one cares
or even knows other than shareholders
last year Microsoft even overtook apple
and became the world's most valuable
company for a minute if we saw this same
thing happen with Amazon instead of
Microsoft we would have seen social
media erupt with outrage and toxicity
yet no one cares because it was
Microsoft somehow they've essentially
become the Visa of the tech space
everyone knows about them and uses them
on a regular basis but no one cares
about them much more than just that
honestly this is probably ideal given
that the spotlight hasn't exactly been
forgiving historically but how has the
company that essentially created the
modern computer experience been able to
avoid the spotlight so effectively well
it's definitely not by accident so
Curacao Microsoft became the world's
largest background company
taking a look back Microsoft wasn't
always such a discreet business in the
80s and 90s Microsoft was very much a
consumer business and that's why we all
know about them today as a front-facing
company they faced much of the same
criticism that today's top tech
companies are subject to many thought
that Microsoft was a gross Monopoly and
it that Bill Gates was a rootless
businessman build social image at the
time it could be compared to that of
Mark Zuckerberg's today but Bill didn't
really care he was the richest man in
the world and Microsoft was more
profitable than ever so he wasn't going
to let some public criticism get to his
head but maybe he should have paid more
attention to the criticism because
pretty soon Regulators got involved in
1992 the Federal Trade Commission would
begin an inquiry into Microsoft's
Monopoly this quickly escalated into a
doj investigation and in 1994 the doj
would order that Microsoft was no longer
allowed to package other Microsoft
products with the sale of window however
one nuanced decree was that Microsoft
could continue packaging in additional
features with Windows it probably would
have been in Microsoft's best interest
to play the safe and avoid testing
Regulators but Microsoft had different
plans the internet was starting to
explode in popularity and it was clear
to Microsoft that the internet was the
next big thing so what better way to
capitalize on the internet than to
launch a browser and this led to the
creation of Internet Explorer in 1995.
if Microsoft stopped right there it
wouldn't have been that bad sure they
were still pushing the boundaries of
being a computer software Monopoly but
they weren't violating any court decrees
right well this was true at the
beginning but this didn't last long it
was clear to Microsoft that if they
really wanted to make Internet Explorer
popular they had to package it with
windows so they would call Internet
Explorer a feature and throw it in with
Windows as you would guess Regulators
weren't exactly a fan of this
classification Internet Explorer was
obviously a product and a Microsoft was
simply calling it a feature to try to
get around the dog settlement at first
The Regulators turned a blind eye to
this but Microsoft kept pushing the
envelope remember the controversy about
Apple slowing down older iPhones well
Microsoft had their own version of this
with Internet Explorer they told users
and the court that if the browser was
uninstalled Windows would run slower and
have more malfunctions this was
obviously completely false and if it
Windows it did slow down it was because
Microsoft programmed it to slow down not
because Internet Explorer actually made
Windows run better eventually Regulators
had enough and in 1998 they would put
their foot down the doj and the attorney
generals of 20 U.S states and the
District of Columbia would do Microsoft
for illegally thwarting competition in
order to protect and extend its softer
Monopoly
foreign
usually it takes forever for Regulators
to get involved but once they're
involved you know they mean business two
perfect examples of this were Standard
Oil and the ATT in 1911 Standard Oil was
broken up into 34 different companies
and 1984 at T was split up into eight
different companies a breakup like this
would have devastated Microsoft and Bill
knew it fortunately for Microsoft though
Bill had already been preparing to fight
such a lawsuit you see it several months
before the lawsuit Microsoft had
actually bailed out Apple if you're
familiar with Apple's history you would
know that they were getting destroyed in
the late 1990s and the company was on
the brink of a bankruptcy even though
Microsoft could have easily watched from
the sidelines as Apple went bankrupt
Bill decided to strike a deal with Steve
instead Steve agreed to drop Apple's
copyright lawsuit against Microsoft and
the bill agreed to invest 150 million
dollars into Apple through this deal Not
only was to Bill able to knock out
Apple's lawsuit against them but he was
able to create some plausible
deniability for himself if Regulators
questioned him about monopolistic
practices bill could point to how he
saved apple and how he's actually Pro
competition unfortunately though
Regulators didn't quite buy Bill's
master plan and on June 7th 2000 they
ordered that Microsoft be broken up into
two separate units one unit would
produce operating systems while the
other would produce additional software
honestly this ruling wasn't even that
bad given that at T was broken up into
eight parts and standard oil was broken
up into 34 Parts but that doesn't mean
that Microsoft was happy with the
verdict they definitely were not gonna
go down without a fight so they filed an
appeal the appeal was instantly
escalated to the Supreme Court and the
justices would surprisingly at all side
with Microsoft but not for the reason
that you would think the Supreme Court
unanimously agreed that Microsoft was
absolutely a monopoly however they
invalidated the breakup order because
the judge who issued the order did not
follow the correct protocols he had
failed to hold hearings on a remedy and
he had also been having secret
interviews with reporters while the case
was ongoing the Supreme Court did not
rule out the possibility of properly
issuing another breakup order but after
being so publicly humiliated it's no
wonder why prosecutors did it not pursue
another breakup order
instead it they would order that
Microsoft to share their application
programming interface with the third
party companies and that a pen I'll be
set up to ensure Microsoft's compliance
Microsoft had basically just won the
lottery they were able to avoid a game
changing breakup of all things to a few
semantics playing Bola as a Brash public
Monopoly had a nearly devastated
Microsoft and Microsoft had escaped with
the Skin of Their Teeth there wasn't no
way that Steve Ballmer or Bill were
gonna let this happen to Microsoft again
and this marked the beginning of
Microsoft's life in a shell
foreign
there was a no question that Microsoft
needed to stop attracting out all of
this public interest if they wanted to
avoid future lawsuits and regulations
but how does such a massive company fade
from the spotlight well the answer is
switching customers Microsoft has always
had an extremely loose policy when it
comes to people pirating their software
in fact bill has publicly admitted that
Microsoft would rather you use a pirated
version of their software than a pirated
or paid version of someone else's
software people don't pay for the
software
and
um
they will though
it's sort of as one as long as they're
going to steal it we want them to steal
ours
I sort of sort of get addicted and then
we somehow figure out how to how to
collect sometime in the next uh
in the next decade so you know it's a
great great place to be involved as you
can see Bill was very much okay with
people pirating their software if it
meant that Microsoft would get more
market share as Bill touched on it the
idea was that they could eventually
figure out some sort of method of
monetization whether that be ads or data
collection by the mid-2000s windows and
the office had basically reached Market
saturation so it was finally time to
collect but they couldn't deploy
something as public as ads or data
collection Regulators were literally
waiting for the next moment that
Microsoft would trip up so that they
could pursue more severe legal action so
directly monetizing customers was off
the table but maybe it was time to look
at monetization differently instead of
trying to monetize the end user directly
maybe it was smarter to monetize it
businesses they had already gotten
people used to it and addicted to
Microsoft products so they could force
businesses institutions and computer
manufacturers to pay for Windows and
office they also so went ahead and
basically made Windows free for end
users so no one could really complain
everyday people weren't directly paying
Microsoft at all and institutions had
better things to do than complain about
Microsoft leveraging their Monopoly and
charging insane markups I gotta say
there was a legitimate reason to
complain if they wanted to though back
in 2010 Microsoft literally had gross
margins above at 80 percent but The
Regulators didn't really care because
they only cared about protecting the
public not institutions they figured
that institutions have the resources and
the capital to protect themselves if
they wanted to and given that the public
wasn't being harmed Regulators turned a
blind eye once again not to mention it
they had bigger fish to fire like
Facebook Google and Amazon who were even
more obvious monopolies so Microsoft has
been more or less left to do it as they
please when it comes to the computer OS
Market
foreign
over time Microsoft has further leaned
into this btb model and that they've
started to offer these businesses other
products like servers and cloud
computing since then this side business
has grown so much that it's actually
started to outshine windows and office
in fact intelligent cloud is now
Microsoft's largest revenue driver
having pulled in 20.9 billion dollars
last quarter this includes all of their
server products and the cloud services
second place goes to their productivity
and the business processes category
which pulled in 16.6 billion dollars
this includes Microsoft Office LinkedIn
and other commercial products and in
last place we have the personal
Computing category which pulled in 14.4
billion dollars and this is what
includes Windows the Xbox Bing and other
consumer products this means that
Microsoft could completely ditch the
consumer market and their business would
only shrink 30 if that in other words
they could ditch the consumer market and
they'd likely still be a trillion dollar
company and that right there here is why
Microsoft has completely avoided the
spotlight in the 80s and 90s Microsoft
was one of the most well-known consumer
businesses in the world but after nearly
being broken up they made a 180 they
pivoted to being an Institutional
business which allowed them to maintain
their Monopoly with little public racism
and legal ramifications and now that
they've made this widget they no longer
need it or want public attention for
them it's better if the media keeps
grilling on Facebook and the Google
while Microsoft continues making just as
much from the background and that's why
Microsoft has been avoiding the
spotlight did you realize what game
Microsoft was playing comment that down
below also drop a like if you can't help
but respect the strategy and of course
consider checking out our Discord
Community to suggest for the video ideas
and to consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one